hey what's up guys my name is Shawna
welcome to another code review the
series in which you guys send me your
projects and your code and I take a look
at it I was gonna say I destroy it but I
was trying to be optimistic I haven't
done one of these in a while but you
guys have been pretty Relentless in
sending me your code like continually
and so I was scrolling I was trying to
decide I should probably do a code
review what should I take a look at and
I saw the subject line here code review
a game about a flying dog from python to
C plus plus that uh picked my interest
and here we are today that's the story
that you probably didn't ask for okay so
Marius has sent this in he has a link to
the repository which we'll take a look
at secondly a few months ago I did a
tutorial on C plus plus and as a first
project I wanted to create the same game
I did a few months before then in Python
so this is almost like a kind of Genesis
remake for those of you who don't know
I'm kind of doing a series on my Channel
at the moment where I'm remaking my
first game that I originally made in
Java in C plus plus this sounds exactly
the same which I believe is also your
case but from C plus plus okay I could
have just read the next sentence here's
the python version okay we're not gonna
look at that I'm currently looking for
some internship to get into C plus
programming so the kind of feedback I'd
love to get would be about code being
clean readable well structured for how
it is without thinking about it being
bigger in the future so this is kind of
a I like it when people point this out
because it's sometimes difficult to do
code reviews because am I trying to kind
of give advice based on the current
project as it stands or kind of more
like almost like long-term advice to you
as a programmer when you will inevitably
probably work with much larger systems
and what kind of design things can fall
apart at scale but would work here so
it's good this is specified so I'm going
to take a look at this code specifically
as it appears as if this is final code
for a flying dog game and not
potentially some kind of I don't know
game engine in the future I only wanted
to make a c plus version of what I
already did are there any good practices
that I missed while coding I try to
implement all that I know but I'm sure
there's a lot more that I'm not aware of
bugs memory leaks errors optimization
methods that could be implemented
although I'm quite happy with
performance basically an impression
someone would get after reviewing the
code and obviously what can be made
better I had so much fun creating the
game that I would that it would be even
better seeing you review it I already
know about some flaws of the program
yeah I know the damn thing doesn't
resize sorry generally that's funny a
lot of values are hard-coded these were
actually left on purpose I thought how
could you improve your code would be an
often asked question on job interviews
Ah that's clever deliberately leave some
low-hanging fruit in there so that you
can be like bam I would do this bam I
would do that it's an interesting
strategy that I don't think I've ever
heard before okay stl2 python Pi game
controls left control for truth space
drop bomb arrows okay sure
there's also a gif containing what the
game looks like don't see the GIF I
don't mind you sharing repository name
but please blow my last name yeah I've
removed the last name as you guys can
see in case you'll trash that project
all right Venom is the name of the dog
that'll explain some variable names best
greetings from Poland hi Poland ah
here's the gif
it's just a game about a flying dog
dealing with enemies this is beautiful
this is this is making my day so far
just download
venomadventures.rah from repository off
yeah I don't know about that my special
thanks for different entities I've used
okay so what I've done is I've actually
set it up in Visual Studio I didn't want
to use J Plus for this I just wanted to
set up in visual studio so I can
actually like debug it if I need to
easily as well as like navigate you know
in my preferred IDE of choice
but uh I will say straight off the bat
that like you've kind of dumped
everything in the main repository it's
funny because you actually have a folder
called Source but it only has like
includes of like third-party libraries
as well as like a lib directory with uh
kind of Linux Library so I also had to
dump a bunch of Windows ones in here
but my point is you should definitely
like use a better directory structure
just move these source files somewhere
else into like again a folder called
Source would have been the perfect spot
for them you've also got like main.exe
your main kind of executable in the
actual like root directory of the
repository so yeah and then like
obviously you've got just the raw file
in in the repository here so I would
just kind of clean this up if we take a
look at Hazel just as an example Hazel
is obviously like a 3D game engine
there's much more stuff going on but you
can see kind of how clean this route
looks we have some directories kind of
high level directories that contain the
actual like meat of everything and then
in this route we just have like things
that are relating to the root of the
repository usually stuff like get the
actual solution file build kind of files
and a readme and a license like it's
really clean and simple compared to
obviously dumping all of your uh kind of
source files here and of course like if
we did that with hazel that would be
crazy that would be like a thousand
source files just in the root of the
repository that would be weird so you
could argue it's a smaller game but
still like obviously move that stuff
into the source directory I don't know
why I spent some time talking about this
anyway moving on I can hit F5
and uh oh boy now before we play this
game are you a beginner programmer who's
struggling to kind of think as a
programmer do you need some help with
math all the way up to the advanced
level well then I've got just the thing
for you it's the sponsor of today's
video brilliant those of you who don't
know what brilliant is it's an amazing
website filled with lots and lots of
courses on various stem topics they have
these really nice like simple
straightforward computer science courses
if you're a beginner you're struggling
to kind of piece together the Logics
required to build programs this can be a
really good starting point but then they
also have like what is one of the most
amazing collection of mouth courses I've
ever seen on the internet I personally
go through these courses to revise more
advanced topics such as calculus and the
reason why I prefer these is because of
how Visual and interactive and engaging
they are when I teach I like to present
things as visually as possible because
when I learn that's what I find works
most effectively for me and that's
exactly what brilliant does all the math
is kind of there visualized for you you
can play with these widgets to see how
it works and how values kind of change
and to top that off they'll also
continuously quiz you to make sure that
you're actually learning because it's
easy to kind of get into the Trap of
just like consuming consuming consuming
next next next next and then at the end
of the day if you've learned nothing but
if you have to answer questions you have
to engage with it it just becomes so
much more memorable now brilliant
actually have a 30-day free trial now so
for 30 days you can go for free to
brilliant.org the channel and just try
it out just see what courses they have
play around with some of their widgets
see if you like it and if you do
brilliant have been nice enough to offer
the first 200 of my subscribers 20 off
an annual membership huge thank you to
brilliant as always for sponsoring this
video alright
it's time to play this right off the bat
I'm actually really enjoying the music
I don't know if that was one of the
different entities you used okay here we
go Main Music alright so you didn't
write the music so I'm a little bit
disappointed but this is a code review
not a music review after all I love this
is this like are these real dogs like
are these your dogs fascinating okay
press space to start the game
okay there's bombs dropping
there's birds uh control right to shoot
what a game this is reminding me of um
I like how the grass is just scrolling
like way too quickly
I must be very good at this game oh you
can draw bombs
does it get any harder than this
oh
I got one life left I see
so I'm this dog I guess and I'm in a
plane and I'm shooting birds
and this just goes on forever right
so the the bombs kind of look like they
destroy the building so I wonder why
that is unlike the trees I guess and
like why am I why do I have bombs
am I supposed to destroy buildings
all right and then I guess if I lose
you earned 2760 points press arrows to
yeah okay the controls
oh okay you get points for destroying
these things I thought it was like a
civilian building I was like why would I
want to destroy that and then you lose
oh you lose points for this
wait so you gain points for hitting
these guys
you lose points for hitting that like
for shooting these anyway I don't think
I should spend time figuring out how
this game works let's get into the code
so um this is the main file as we can
see and there's already some things I
have to probably talk about which are
these Global variables at the top which
is not the best thing to do
um now you came from python so I'll kind
of keep that in mind but since you kind
of asked me to almost look at this as if
I was interviewing you for like a job
position I'm going to try and do this
code review I guess from that point of
view so again the first thing I think I
would notice here just from looking at
this file is these Global variables up
the top why would I even notice them in
the first place so when I see global
variables like this what it kind of
shows I guess to me primarily is that
you uh might not be able to structure
your code correctly like you might not
have the tools required to like be able
to properly use I guess like object and
memory any lifetimes you might not have
the programming experience to be able to
properly share access to certain apis I
guess between files and classes because
it's relatively easy to just make
something kind of global or static or
whatever and just give the whole
application access to it but that's not
generally something we do because it's
quite messy the cleanup process becomes
more difficult memory lifetimes become
harder to track and it could even result
in like apis being used incorrectly if
everything is just accessible and you
can do whatever you want the other
reason I guess is that there's
fundamentally no reason for it if we
look at something like game or game
intro they're probably only really used
here because game obviously game kind of
calls every single function or game
intro you know these things call all the
functions from here current level is
probably something that I imagine would
need to be switched somehow but you can
see that it's switched from this actual
like a while loop inside this function
itself so therefore there's probably
nothing else accessing this so if we do
like just a little search across this
code base for game intro
you can see that the only place it's
used is inside Main and if we search for
game outro it's a similar story so the
first question is why are these up here
why not just make these kind of
I guess local variables tied to this
scope and get rid of them up here and
then of course change this to be the
outro type now I'm I'm guessing it's
also the same kind of story with game so
what we can do is also take that put it
over here and that's probably F5 to
build you can see that works perfectly
fine so that's kind of the first thing
that jumps out at me you always want to
make sure that you limit variables to as
small of a scope as possible but what
you've done is you've literally made it
the largest scope possible like you
didn't even have these kind of declared
as static which would which would have
at least limited this to be only
accessible kind of within this main.cbp
file if you don't make it static if you
make a global like this what that means
if I go into a random file like bird dot
uh CBP I can literally just be like game
game I can declare it like as an extern
and then I can just use it as if it was
perfectly accessible in here I'll
obviously still need kind of like the
definition of game but you can see that
that means that I can do whatever game
wants to do through like render or
whatever I can do all of that stuff from
within this file I'm sorry this needs to
be a uh pointer of course whatever is
done to game from here I can also do it
from here suddenly just by doing that so
it effectively is a completely Global
variable whereas if it's at least static
that means that this isn't going to work
because you're kind of limiting that
variable to only be visible within this
translation unit which is this CPP file
but again in this case not necessary at
all just make game be a local variable
tied to here now that brings me to my
second point which is why is this just a
raw pointer I'm all for raw pointers
that I want to say I don't want people
to get the wrong idea that I'm just like
immediately Banning raw pointers
throughout code bases because some
people do have that opinion and that's a
really weird and incorrect I would say
opinion the fact is that sometimes
memory management is really black and
white it's just like I need this object
to exist within this scope that's it
that's really really simple there's no
like oh what if another thread uses it
and then keeps it for longer than my
thread and there's no there's really no
complicated semantics with this lifetime
at all it's just game exists for the
duration of this main function that is
it now if we scroll down you're not even
deleting game which is actually okay
surprisingly I know a lot of people
probably fight me for this but if if you
have an object if you have a memory
allocation that literally lasts for the
duration of the entire application's
lifetime you don't need to delete it you
should it's just a good habit to get
into and also if you have any kind of
shutdown Behavior inside your game
Destructor that's important so you have
a virtual Destructor called game which
does nothing right and it's a virtual
Destructor
for some reason is this a no it might be
a base class I guess but that would also
be weird or maybe game outro and intro
or subclasses of Games game actresses oh
wow these are all subclasses of the game
why that's bizarre and did they do
anything no
well possibly actually private CSA no
that's just default okay sure you've
made the disruptive virtual just in case
subclasses override it will get into
this weird hierarchy in a minute but um
in general like that's why it's a good
idea to call delete game because then
you're actually freeing that memory and
call in the destructor now you do have a
function called clean which destroys a
bunch of stuff so you could put this
into the destructor and then that way
this line of code would kind of
essentially execute this function or the
contents of that function so this is
what you would consider good practice
because you're freeing resources you've
allocated whenever you have a new you
should also have a delete that's kind of
the rule even though again technology
speaking you don't need to free memory
if you're about to terminate the
application and it might actually be
faster probably will be faster to just
not do that because the operating system
will reclaim all the memory you've
allocated immediately in one go very
quickly and you don't have to worry
about going through every item you've
ever made and destroying it unless it
has necessary shutdown Behavior but
people usually get upset when beginners
or inexperienced programmers will say I
told that because it might teach bad
habits but whatever so this is the
lifetime of game we've basically
determined the lifetime it begins here
and it ends essentially at the end of
this scope so what that means is we can
use an object that automates that kind
of Lifetime management such as a unique
pointer now I'm going to include the
memory header file over here that will
let us use that and basically what we
can do is instead of making game a game
pointer we can make it an SCD unique
pointer and then we use game as the
template parameter so that's what
happens and then this new game changes
to be an SCD make unique you can still
keep new game if you want you can pop it
in like that that's no big deal does the
exact same thing in this case with a
shared pointer you generally want to use
make shed but where the unique pointer
doesn't matter so if I just do make
unique maybe it looks a bit cleaner and
we don't have to write new because that
triggers some people apparently uh we
have this so unique point of game Eagles
make unique game and then what that
basically means is we just straight up
do not need this but because what will
happen is this unique pointer is
obviously allocated on the stack like as
in it's not a unique pointer pointer
meaning it has to get nude and deleted
so what that means is the unique point
is Lifetime is tied to this stack to
this kind of scope and then when the
scope ends it will call the destructor
of unique pointer and that will delete
game that will actually call delete on
game just like make unique we'll call
new so you can see make unique calls new
and then the unique pointer Destructor
will actually call delete but it's a
little bit more complicated in the
unique pointer code because you can
specify like custom destructors and
custom deleters if you want so it's all
like behind templates so that kind of
automates that process for us and you
can see this is already kind of looking
better this I think immediately to
someone interviewing you we kind of you
kind of look at this and you'll be like
all right well you're using you know
unique pointers is aware of like object
lifetimes and Scopes and stuff that's
good and you could also use a shared
pointer in this kind of case that would
technically work but because the
lifetime is so kind of simple it's just
discover this function we're not going
to be kind of share sharing that
object's lifetime lifetime control I
guess with other places in our code base
we should use unique pointers because
they have less overhead they have no
overhead basically whereas a shared
pointer does have some like performance
overhead now the other thing you can
consider is also does this actually need
to be Heap allocated because unique
pointer and what you had before with new
game that causes a heap allocation
you're basically allocating the contents
of that object on the Heap now there is
a lot of stuff here and actually you
even using unique pointers so you're
obviously aware of unique pointers which
also begs the question why didn't you
use it here but anyway you can see
there's a lot of stuff here like look we
got vectors upon vectors we've got looks
like your whole kind of everything is in
here so that might be a little bit too
much data to store on the stack again
that decision is kind of yours you get
about a megabyte of Stack space usually
you can change that in your build
settings but by default it's one
megabyte but if you did want to make it
on the stack you can just do game game
like that and you're done that's it and
then you just use it except with a DOT
instead of an arrow and that will
that will work as it did before and
because it's a stack allocated object
just like unique pointer was it will be
destroyed at the end of this kind of
scope and your memory will be released
but if you did want it to still be a
heap allocation this is the way to go so
that's really my first uh bit of advice
obviously for game intro exact same
situation like you'd take this and you'd
make this game intro be a unique pointer
with make unique that would look
something like this and then you just
don't need to delete it at the end which
again you weren't doing but that will
properly call the destructor and
actually free the memory as well all
right we've spent like so much time
talking about this easy thing but that's
just that's how it is code reviews are
long um okay so let's actually focus on
what you're doing so the first thing
that happens kind of really is the game
construct is called so let's take a look
at what you do in there when I read this
kind of card I guess I could just
obviously just browse through the files
arbitrarily but I like to kind of go
through the code in like order of
execution and if you just like place a
breakpoint with F9 F5 that's a really
good way to do that because you can see
now I can just kind of use the uh use
these kind of um what is even called
like break point commands like debugging
controls whatever I can use that like
hit f11 you know step into this and it's
just very easy to see what's going on
especially if you have like you know
virtual kind of you have like class
hierarchies you might have overwritten
functions it might be hard to find
manually but with the debugger obviously
it will step into the right function
that's being called you can even like
hover over variables it's a really good
way of kind of exploring that stuff
speaking of which your Xbox and ypods
look very weird what are they set to our
sdl window position centered okay so
that just happens to be
some kind of weird mask of course it is
okay anyway so we're in in it we have a
bunch of initialization code that's fine
we yeah basically just in it all the
kind of STL stuff initialize textures
Blackbird okay hello
all right so this
um
yeah this needs to be talked about as
well I guess there's a lot of code here
and I get what these functions doing if
we just collapse them quickly you can
see we have initialized textures for all
the different types of Sprites we kind
of have we have black bird green bird
blue bird Fireball explosion and bird
here so each of these though first of
all it contains a lot of boilerplate
code that you don't need they are kind
of individually unique in a way like for
example if we go to like I don't know
explosion you can see that loads way
more stuff because I guess this is maybe
some kind of Animation I didn't actually
notice I'm guessing it's like an
animation or something but it has to
load like a whole bunch of these and it
pushes it back into the Container but
this kind of like really the only thing
that changes here if you have a look at
these two functions the only thing that
changes here is the quantity of images
that are loaded as well as the actual
file paths now the problem with the way
that you've written it is that it's just
this is just a lot of duplicated code
and it's kind of hard to read it's easy
to make mistakes like you may have
mistyped something it's basically taking
the kind of specific data that you care
about and want to set and surrounding it
with a whole bunch of code that is just
kind of making it harder to read it's
making it more of a Bose we want to keep
it like as lean as possible so that we
can focus on the part that we need to
see which in this case is like the file
path so what I would propose you do here
is you can basically just I'm just going
to write some code you can make some
like initialized textures or whatever
just initialize textures and then what
we can kind of make that do is we'll
take in a container that's fine we'll
have to take in the renderer as well but
then what we can do is we can just take
take in like a list of file paths and
this could just be like a vector of
strings or a vector of SCD faster than
path or whatever so we could have our
actual kind of textures here so texture
paths that could be
um I'll just make it strings to be
simple here and I would take that in as
like a const reference
so here we are with our strings
I don't know why that's still why is
that still red little Studio okay
whatever it's red but it works control
F7 if there's ever a doubt by the way
you're not sure if this is just like
your ID playing up or Visual Studio
playing up or whatever if it's an actual
real error you can just hit Ctrl F7 to
build this one specific file as long as
it's a buildable file like a CPP file
and then you can see it succeeds which
means that this is wrong so then what I
can do here is I can kind of still
create this like uh temperature so temp
surface gets kind of yeah freed and then
overridden so what I can do is just go
through all of these texture paths here
so I'll just do like const Auto path in
texture paths we'll create the surface
like this I'll just copy like this
entire kind of block here I guess we'll
pass in the path and this this one a
const chart so we'll do path.c string
we'll create a texture from the surface
We'll add it to the container and then
we'll free it so there's no difference
in what this is doing right you're
reusing the variable name but you're
still obviously freeing it and re-making
it so you might as well not be and
that's really all that needs to be done
so now what happens is this initialize
textures Blackbird this function can
just look like basically this you could
just do initialize textures let's pass
in the container and the renderer and
then you can just list out
your file paths that you want to load
and I can do that in between these two
kind of brackets if I want to I don't
know how I want to format them yet but
basically you go through and you just
specify like here's you know this guy
here's this guy okay and then we just
have like
two and three and that's kind of it so
if I hit Ctrl F7 you can see that builds
successfully again I get all the errors
might restart Visual Studio in a minute
but that should do the exact same thing
as what you have here but you can see
how much easier it is to read you can
format it a little bit nicer if you want
to as well okay I already started visual
studio and there you go so we can get
rid of this
and we now have that and you can imagine
that if you had something like that
explosion with a whole lot more you know
what do we have here like it's explosion
one through like 22 you know that would
just be a nice listed out kind of
version of this now of course you could
over engineer this as well and make like
a system that like will you can give it
like the beginning of a string and it
will try and increment the number until
it can't find any more files with that
kind of prefix that's also valid that
would mean that it doesn't matter how
many kind of animated frames you have of
that texture you could just load all of
them it's kind of like loading an image
sequence I guess but if we're trying to
keep it simple not over engineer it too
much this is a really good compromise
took me like two minutes to write and
then of course it just makes everything
way nicer I think let's just hit F5 to
make sure that still works so what is
that that was the black bird or
something
blackbird
is this this is this the black bird I'm
guessing that still works yeah okay so
it is animated I just I didn't even
notice that in the first
um I guess because the main character is
not animated all the budget went towards
the enemies
Okay cool so that seems to work and just
for fun let's Chuck in an explosion
frame as well so we could make like the
last frame we could see we can easily
add a frame as well we'd just be like oh
yeah also load that in and make that
part of the animation so I'm guessing
now the black birds will kind of have an
explosion frame okay they don't
is that because let's make the explosion
frame earlier on is that because it's
like hard-coded to be a certain amount
of frames long oh my gosh it is because
see that makes that now they kind of
disappear that must be a bad explosion
frame let's go to like 10. no it still
just disappears
interesting all right so that is the
test is being initialized we're just
scraping the surface of this so what I
think we're going to do is we want to
split this up into like a multiple
episode code review like we did with the
physics engine if you enjoyed this code
review please don't forget to hit the
like button let me know what you thought
about my feedback this is a good
opportunity for really everyone I guess
in the comments section to provide
feedback to the author of this code
probably going to regret saying that but
next time we'll dive like right into the
code a little bit quicker and hopefully
cover a lot more ground thank you guys
for watching don't forget to check out
brilliant using my link in description
below and I'll see you guys next time
goodbye